hi
in this video I'm going to talk about
how to download graphpad prism graphpad
prism is a very important software for
graphical analysis statistics and
research quality graph making so that is
why you have to know how to download
graphpad prism and the latest version of
rapid prism is graphpad prism 6 in order
to download we first open our web
browser then we would go to we would
just write graphpad prism 7 free
download and then it would redirect us
to the site of graphpad prism then there
is a portion where you have to do
registration you have to enter your
email confirm your email first name last
name and then you have to do submit I
have done this before and after doing
this they would send you a link in your
email and in that particular email they
would give another link when you click
on that link it would redirect to
another page and you have to do that
registration process again when you do
that registration process they would
give you a page from where you can
download that graphpad after downloading
successfully this thing they would send
you another email containing the
accession code so here is the accession
code you have to copy that accession
code into the particular area given in
the graph pad after doing that graph pad
would be activated so my graph pad is
already activated so let's click on the
graph but prism 6 prism 7 and it would
open so here you can see it's our
graphpad prism and now we can start
working on it and I hope this video
helped you and if you like my video
please give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to subscribe and please leave
your comments below thank you
you